Film Courage: You talked about switching up
cognitive processes.
Are there certain movies that seem to do that
in a 2-hour span where you are gong from one
emotion to the next?
Dr. Connie Shears, Author and Professor - Crean
at Chapman University: Sure, there are lots
of movies that fast forward your emotions.
Most of your JACK REACHER kind of solve-the-crime,
stay-out-of-danger, moving at a very quick
pace.
Those movies tend not to involve much humor
or much regret.
Those movies tend to be based on fear and
anticipation so they keep kind of a higher
heart rate going while you are watching.
The movie that are more psychological or involve
an aspect of reflection, thinking about your
memories.
So 500 DAYS or 50 FIRST DATES, those kind
of movies that portray people who have lost
memory or are not forming memories properly
are very engaging, real successful in the
box office.
More engaging for an audience who may not
be a hero or a daredevil or that kind of a
person, maybe can watch those but has a lingering
appreciate for someone whose mind is not working
exactly the way their’s is.
So lots of movies come at different cognitive
processes and in forming a story around not
working cognitive processes, some kind of
brain injury that has changed that person,
you get a lot of fascination from the viewer’s
perspective because everybody relates to forgetting
at some time or another.
Everybody has had a forgetful experience.
What is it like to not be able to form a memory
so that you live in a forgotten state?
Those are some interesting psychological brain
processes that have been presented and done
well in the theaters.
One of the aspects that we point out in [Connie
and Paul Joseph Gulino’s book] The Science
of Screenwriting is how skilled screenwriters
build in the contrast of emotions.
So there’s been some studies done and researchers
have used eye trackers in audiences such that
they can tell where the audiences eyes are
focused on the screen during which kinds of
movies.
And because we can measure like how long the
eyes stay on the character and how often the
eyes move off of the character we can translate
those eye movements into attentional factors.
And we now understand that timing is critical.
So a viewer can take about 3 minutes of tension
of that kind of bond (fighting with the shark
or whatever that is) and there needs to be
a break or the eyes are going to soccolld.
You can take too much tension so we need a
relief.
So if you’ll notice in the [JAMES] BOND
movies it’s really brief.
It’s about a minute and a half where it’s
bad stuff kind of tension and then there’s
a segue whether that means it’s a further
away shot, long distance shot or a scan to
the boat that is coming to the rescue or whatever
interruption in order to give the nerves,
the brain processes that are building tension
in that watcher a break.
And it has to be at least at 30-60-90 second
breaks to scan away before you can reengage
in a tight emotional situation.
So we know those processes are happening in
daily life and that when people go to a movie
they anticipate experiencing deeper tension,
more dramatic exchanges in order to maintain
their attention.
You still have to give those interactive breaks
so that there is a release and then a reengagement
in the tension and conflict.